I was told that if I wanted to see how
the US will play a part in India's
energy future I should come here a coal
power plant believe it or not erected
right in the middle of Delhi
mr. ambassador nice to meet you nice to
meet you I I love the movie set
apocalyptic on the one side of the
railroad tracks on the other side of the
railroad tracks this wonderful solar
field this is the problem and how we
conquer it this is now probably the
single biggest pathway of our
cooperation between the US and India in
the years ahead the clean energy space
although 400 companies Nordhoff
companies from us are here in India
looking very actively I think what's
really exciting is that this has caught
hold here in a way that it never has
before
what are the challenges ahead here to
meet the target that India has set just
in solar the financing challenge is
about a hundred billion dollars Wow it's
a hundred billion dollars of private
capital of government money of India's
resources so a huge challenge in getting
that business climate right to actually
attract that investment in terms of jobs
do the equation for us what does this
represent we bring solar panels from
Perrysburg Ohio from pasola
in water technology from Colorado in in
Denver so we end up creating a lot of
manufacturing jobs in the United States
so some of these panels are made in Ohio
so summer markets in the United States
is not donating a time equipment raw
materials everybody makes money
absolutely look it's good for national
security reasons it's good to combat
climate change it's good for economic
development reasons here in India but
also in the United States when I first
got here I I saw nothing but problems
and and if you start examining the
problems they all become opportunity I
mean overwhelming opportunity we're
really optimistic about this space we're
really optimistic about the way the u.s.
and India have come together to tackle
this challenge